Welcome back to Garys Economics
today we are going to explain
how wealth inequality affects the economy
okay so this is going to be one of the key
educational videos of the Youtubeum
First you're gonna need to understand what wealthis
um so if you haven't seen it I would recommend
watching the "what is wealth" video but I'll give a
brief explanation here when we talk about wealth
we're not talking about jobs or incomes we're
talking about who owns the physical resources
um of our country and of our economy so: who
owns the buildings, who owns the houses, who
owns the land, who owns the natural resources,
who owns the debt that is a big form of wealth
um that's we're talking about um and before I
start if anyone prefers like a text version of
these kinds of things explained it's all on mywebsite www.wealtheconomics.org on the section called
'the wealth unequal economy' Ok so to understand
how wealth inequality affects the economy
first we need to understand what wealth inequality
looks like and to explain that I'm going to go
over what a more wealth equal economy would look
like and compare that to what our wealth unequal
economy would look like so when we talk about
wealth inequality we're talking about who owns
the assets so in a wealth equal economy and I'm
not talking about necessarily perfect equality
um but in a broadly equal economy what that
would mean is most people would have some decent
ownership of assets so most people would for
example own their own home and they would also own
some share of the the productive economy so they
might own some part of a factory or a business or
of some farmland or some energy production
resources there's the homes there's also
commercial buildings and there's also productive
resources and it was the equal economy most people
would own some parts of all of those things um
that would mean most people wouldn't have to
worry about paying rent or very large mortgage and
also people would be getting some passive income
from the ownership of the commercial economy
that they own um in that economy most people
would be quite secure because they're own their
own property and they also have passive income
um and they would have some extra money to spend
now in a world of unequal economy what you have
is a world in which the vast majority of the
physical resources are owned by a very small group
of extremely wealthy people um on top of that
ina very wealth unequal economy the rest of the
people would also be in debt to the very wealthy
people um when I say this some people might assume
because I'm very opposed to inequality that
I'm suggesting the UK is a very unequal economy
um actually on this sliding scale of this the
UK is not a particularly unequal economy if we
compare to most countries in the world and to
history; a lot of countries in the world do not
have many landowners many property owners
ordinarypeople don't own property so most countries
are very unequal and in the past the UK has been
very unequal at the moment the UK does have a
relatively large property owning middle class
so the UK at the moment is somewhere in the
middle but it's moving towards the wealth unequal
side okay so these are the two examples what an
economy can look like a wealth equal economy
where everybody owns some stuff some assets
their own property and get some passive income
from what they own a whilst unequal economy where
most people own very little or nothing and
a tiny group of people own enormous amounts
so what does the wealth of an equal economy do?
how does it affect ordinary people? well the first
obvious thing is that in a wealth and equal
economy most people don't own their own home
if they do it will be with a large mortgage
they also don't own any share in the natural
resources which um includes the food production
industry the energy production industry like
essential things to live like this um so
in a very wealth unequal economy a lot of people
are quite insecure because they don't own the
assets which produce the things essential
for life like housing like food like energy
which means they have to work um so in a wealth
unequal economy most people you know really
desperately need to work pretty much all the time
otherwise they literally can't live in a home they
can't eat and again the UK is not at this extreme
level yet although it's going that direction um
on the flip side
in a wealth unequal economy the rich people are
extraordinarily rich; very very very very rich um
at this point it's important to understand
another thing that I've been trying to explain
on the channel I mentioned a few times which is
that rich people spend a much lower percentage of
their income than ordinary people this is just a
natural consequence of the fact that the income is
so high so if you consider Rishi Sunak he probably
makes an income from his wealth of about 30 or 40
million pounds a year if you imagine yourself if
you had a passive income of 30-40 million pounds
a year you probably wouldn't spend all of it you'd
spend you know even if you spent half of it you'd
be living an unbelievably luxurious life and you
probably use the rest to save up so rich people
have this huge income but they tend to save most
of their income so because we know that ordinary
people spend their income and rich people save
their income in a very unequal economy all of
that income your rent your mortgage the profits
of Corporations goes to this small amount of
rich people who tend not to spend very much so
what that means is we know in an unequal economy
demand for consumption is low overall consumption
will be quite low because all of the income is
going to people who don't spend much money and
this immediately creates a problem right because
on the one hand we have a huge group of people
who desperately need to work in order to live
and on the other hand you have a small group
of people who own the essentials that you need
to live and they don't want to spend very much
money so straight away you can see that there's
a bit of a imbalance here basically lots of
people desperately need work because they
don't own homes or food the people who own
the homes and the food don't really want to
spend much money so you immediately end up
in a situation in an unequal economy where
wages are quite low and that is because you
have a lot of desperate workers and a very
small amount of rich people who don't want
to spend this is compounded by the fact that
in a modern economy a lot of the wealth which rich
people own is technology um especially nowadays
rich people own very high tech factories that
are able to produce an enormous amount of goods
with very few workers if you look at for example
farming farming used to require a huge amount of
workers to produce a lot of food whereas now in
this country almost no workers are in farming
and yet still a huge amount of food is produced um
so what that means is today these wealthy people
who own huge amounts of assets including your
home your mortgage the food production energy
production um they also have a huge amount of very
high technology which means they don't need many
workers so in a big picture what you have here
in unequal economy is a huge amount of workers
who are desperate to work otherwise they will
literally starve and a tiny number of people
who don't want to spend much money and don't need
any workers because they've got machines anyway
so I think this is the first key point if you
understand this broad structure of an of an
unequal economy it is quite inevitable that
unequal economies will have very low wages
um and that is exactly for the reason which I've
just explained to you unequate economies have
large numbers of desperate workers small numbers
of people who can spend who have who spend a very
low proportion of their income and have very
advanced technology such that they don't need
a workers so that's the first thing in a very
unequal economy wages are low because there's a
lot of disparate workers and a very small number
of people who are not spending a lot of money um
but if the rich are not spending
money what are they doing with it
well what rich people like to do is save
very large amounts of their income and that
leads to the next big consequence of um wealth
inequality and we touched this a little bit in the
economics video some people think that if the
rich have a lot of money and they save it that's
great because it will lead to Investments
and a growing economy but we also know that
in the world and equal economy there's very low
levels of overall spending demand for spending
so in that environment it is quite
unlikely that businesses will try to expand
um you know since 2008 as the economy has
become more and more unequal we've actually seen
record increase in wealth of the richest and
also extremely low rates of investment and
in my opinion this is and you can ask businesses
this is largely because the consumer is quite weak
people are not spending much money if people
are not spending money business don't expand
so what do rich people do
with the money that they save
if they're not investing in growing new
businesses growing the economy building new assets
um well what they can do is
they can buy the existing assets
and if rich people are phenomenally Rich then we
know that they have huge income and if they're
using that income to buy assets this will push
asset prices up so this is in in essence the
mirror of wages being low in an unequal economy a
big amount of the income goes to the rich they're
not spending it so wages are low they are saving
it so asset prices are higher um so that's the
second big fact about non-equal economy is that
asset prices are high and probably most noticeably
and most problematically for Ordinary People
ordinary families that includes house prices
um and that is quite simply because in a in an
unequal economy the rich get huge amount of money
they use it to buy assets all assets go up not
just houses but including houses um leading to
the second major fact of unequal economies in
unequal economies house prices are very high um
and these first two major facts of an unequal
economy which is number one wages are low and
number two assets including house prices
are higher they obviously interact in a
very troubling way right because if your wage is
low and at the same time house prices are high
then as the economy becomes more and more unequal
you inevitably move into a situation where buying
property becomes increasingly impossible for
people from poor families regardless of what they
do for a job or in their education I think we're
starting to see that a lot more visibly here in
the UK but it's also I think become more visible
in Europe in the US in Japan in a lot of countries
in Australia um and an obvious consequence of
that is that social Mobility becomes very very
low because if you can't buy a house even if
you get a good job then it becomes extremely
difficult to move from being a poor family
to being a comfortable family and number two
Financial Security becomes increasingly impossible
to attain for ordinary families um and I think I
probably don't think I need to labor this that
much because it's becoming increasingly really
really visible to a lot of families and people
especially young people around the world that
wages are low especially compared to house
prices and that means that even if you do
work pretty hard and get a great job it becomes
increasingly very difficult to own property
and then that makes it difficult to comfortably
financially own a family or even safer retirement
okay so those are our three main features of an
unequal economy so far number one low wages number
two high asset price including house prices number
three low levels of social Mobility number four uh
low levels of Financial Security for most people
um another couple of features that I think are
interesting of a wealth and equal economy is um
concentration of what happens in the economy so
in an equal economy we all have some income
and we will have some extra money to spend
and then that means the economy tends to produce
things that Ordinary People want because ordinary
people are driving the economy ordinary people
have money to spend have money in their pockets
um but in a very unequal economy wages are low
house prices are high so Ordinary People don't
have much money to spend but the rich have huge
amounts of money to spend and the more unequal the
economy becomes the more money the rich have um
what that means is as an economy becomes more and
more unequal the spending of the rich becomes much
more powerful relative to the spending of the poor
and um you start to see that reflected in what
kind of Industries are successful in an economy
so in a relatively more equal economy
like we had in the 50s 60s 70s
and into the 80s in this country um economies
were really driven by the spending of the middle
class and by middle class I really mean like
average person in an average financial situation
and I might know it's a big boom in you know
producing cause for ordinary people or even
close for ordinary people um whereas now as
the economy is coming more and more unequal
the economy is Shifting towards the spending of
the very rich so we know that rich people save
huge amounts of money so you're seeing growth
in asset management and investment Industries
um but the spending that rich people do do even
though it's low as a percentage of their income
tends to be on luxury so what you're seeing now I
think is really interesting we have this massive
cost of living crisis and people are struggling
to eat and to eat their homes but I live in London
and I went to the center of London the other
day Soho and it's popping you know the the
rich people are spending money in inexpensive
restaurants because they've got a lot of money
um and obviously what that means is um you
know ordinary restaurants will close down
because their customers ordinary people
have no money and they'll be replaced by
luxury restaurants because the rich have lots
of money so the next fact in an unequal economy
the economy tends to focus on the industries
which which people enjoy such as luxury Industries
and that leads me to my next point
which is geographic concentration
so in an equal economy we are all workers but
we are all also Spenders and what that means
is wherever there are people there are Spenders
which means that in any town or Village or city
you you can have a functioning economy where we
all work with one another because we all have a
job and we all have an income and we can we can
work one another you know the plumber can fix
my sync and I can do his well I could teach his
kids economics I suppose he can watch my videos
um but you know different people do
different jobs for for one another
um but when you have a very unequal economy
the group of people who are Spenders and the
group of people who are workers becomes totally
different so rich people don't work because they
have huge passive income and Ordinary People
don't spend because they have very low wages
what this means is in parts of the country where
there are not many rich people living there or
going there the economy ceases to function because
you all need to pay your rent to the rich you
need to you need to pay money to the rich to get
access to the things that you need which they own
um but they don't live in your city so
and they don't come to your city so you
can't get the things that you need from them
and I think what we've seen massively over
the last 20 30 years here in the UK but
also across European parts of the US is
um parts of the country where rich people don't
live or don't go have basically ceased to be
economically viable it's become very difficult
to get jobs or well-paid jobs in those areas
um sometimes people like to say that this is just
because of a growth of big cities but actually if
you look in detail what we've seen is not us
not a growth in popularity of big cities but
really a growth in popularity of anywhere where
rich people go so I live in Oxford for two years
when I was doing my masters um Oxford is not a
big city it's a small City but Oxford is a very
very expensive place to live I think it's possibly
the second most expensive place to live in the UK
Cambridge is also very expensive to live and
this is not because they're big cities but it's
because these are places where rich people
send their kids to study um you know if you
look at ski villages in the Swiss Alps or popular
holiday resorts for the wealthy in in the United
States these places have become really really
expensive despite the fact that they are not
um big cities so what people economists sometimes
think is a move towards big cities is actually in
my opinion perfectly a manifestation of a very
unequal economy which is in an unequal economy
you need to work for rich people because rich
people own the things that you need to live um so
if there are no rich people in your city or if you
are not spending money in your city then your city
basically ceases to function economically and that
means that young people in in um you know lots of
places with very you know proud histories such
as much of the north of this country um you know
huge sways of places like Spain and Italy um you
know places like the rust spot in the US um they
basically cease to function economically because
the people who live there are a middle class that
is disappearing they're losing assets that they're
rich um so essentially in a very unequal economy
you have to live with the rich people spend their
time and spend their money which leads to very
high levels of geographic concentration so people
have to live wherever the rich people are near to
them and we're definitely seeing that with um the
big growth in a difference between the big cities
and the the popular fashionable places in Europe
and the US compared to the rest of the country
um one knock-on consequence of that is that
you start to see increasing density of the
biggest cities um you know if you go and look at
really really unequal places in the world like
like India or like Brazil we've seen this for a
long time which is ordinary people who don't own
any natural resources have to flood to wherever
the rich people are and it leads to very dense
um slums basically on the outskirts of cities um
and that this is inevitably what happens when you
have very high inequality which is which is poor
people who don't own any assets who need to go and
live where the rich people are um and increasingly
we're seeing it in London you know I grew up
in ilford um it was not very dense when I was a
kid and it was um family homes and now those homes
have all been expanded and they're packed full of
people um often not families often rented out by
the room and that is because people both in this
country and all across Europe and all across the
world need to live where the rich people are
in a very unequal economy um and the knock-on
consequence of that is obviously that you need to
live in places where the rents are higher because
if you need to live in the same place where
the rich people live then you are competing
with the rich people for space they have enormous
amount of income and they can drive the renter
okay so I think that basically covers
it one more thing I wanted to do
was just explain the last most dangerous
thing about wealth inequality which
um I've mentioned a few times before on the
channel which is that when World inequality is
very high it means that ordinary people end up
paying pretty much all of their monthly annual
wage to the rich in the forms of rent mortgage
food and bills which means that there is a huge
cash flow from Ordinary People to the rich
every day every week every month every year
um again if you still like my favorite guy I
really hope it'll be prime minister one day
um if we consider his 40 million income passive
income that he gets every year from you from your
mortgage payments um he will use that to buy
the rest of the assets which means that next
year wealth inequality will be worse which means
that next year the payments the cash flows from
Ordinary People to the rich will be higher which
means that wealth and quality will get worse still
so it has a very dangerous spiraling unstable
mechanism which is probably the key thing that I
saw back when I was a Trader and I realized wow
this is going to get worse and worse and worse
um until we stop it and it will it
will get worse and worse and worse
so I think that concludes my lesson um the main
key points again it's all on the website if you
want to read it wealth economics.org the wealth
and equal economy but the key points are wealth
required leads to low wages very expensive asset
prices including house prices low social Mobility
very difficult situation to attain Financial
stability uh concentration in luxury Industries
Geographic concentration in in big cities and
the places where the rich spend their money
um and a spiraling worsening of the situation
oh and one last thing um because the
ordinary people end up in a situation where
they have very little excess money it creates
a situation where governments can't raise
much tax from Ordinary People but often also
don't raise tax from the rich for a variety of
reasons the rich or newspapers on lobbyists and
also on accountants so you end up in a situation
where the government ends up not being able to pay
for its services and and coming back on public
services which in this country called austerity
um so I'll recap it once more low wages High house
prices no social Mobility no Financial stability
economic concentrations luxury Industries
Geographic concentration in big cities expensive
rents and austerity and it gets worse year after
year after year so I hope I put so energy I hope
this video has been useful um if you like it
please share it use it to educate your friends
and your family um share the message because we're
trying to build a movement against it and if we
don't do anything things get worse and worse and
worse and that will be really bad for everyone
so uh thank you very much we're going to do more
educational videos like videos like this but um
subscribe and like and press the Bell that's the
Bell yeah and um check out our tick tock thank you